NEW YORK CITY.
WELCOME TO "THE FIVE."
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FINALLY
ADMITTING THE PRESIDENT FLAT OUT
LIED WHEN HE ACCUSED BORDER
PATROL AGENTS OF WHIPPING
MIGRANTS PIER THE HEAD OF THE
BORDER PATROL ANNOUNCING THE
RESULTS OF A MONTH-LONG
INVESTIGATION INTO THE INCIDENT
WHERE DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA
CLAIMED THE AGENTS WERE STRIKING
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSERS.
>> AFTER AN EXTENSIVE REVIEW,
THE U.S. ATTORNEY ISSUED THEIR
DECISION NOT TO PROSECUTE THE
CASE.
OPR FOUND NO EVIDENCE FOR THE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS INVOLVED IN
THIS INCIDENT THAT STRUCK ANY
PERSON WITH THEIR RAIN
INTENTIONALLY OR OTHERWISE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE FALSE
CLAIMS THE BORDER AGENTS
WHIPPING MIGRANTS WAS QUICKLY
DEBUNKED BUT REMEMBER, THAT
DIDN'T STOP THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FROM SMEARING THE
BORDER PATROL ON HORSEBACK WHO
WERE JUST DOING THEIR JOB.
>> TO SEE PEOPLE TREATED LIKE
THEY DID, HORSES RUNNING OVER
PEOPLE BEING STRAPPED, IT IS
OUTRAGEOUS.
I PROMISE YOU, THOSE PEOPLE WILL
PAY.
>> AS WE ALL KNOW, IT INVOKES
IMAGES OF SOME OF THE WORST
MOMENTS OF OUR HISTORY WHERE
THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR HAS BEEN
USED AGAINST THE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY AND
AGAINST AFRICAN AMERICANS DURING
TIMES OF SLAVERY.
>> I SAW HORRIFYING IMAGES THAT
DO NOT REFLECT WHO WE ARE, WHO
WE ASPIRE TO BE, OR THE
INTEGRITY AND VALUES ARE TRULY A
ROLE OF PERSONAL AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
>> THE HORRIFIC VIDEO AT THE CDP
OFFICERS ON HORSES USING BRUTAL
AND INAPPROPRIATE MEASURES
AGAINST INNOCENT PEOPLE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE FOUR
AGENTS AREN'T OUT OF THE WAS
JUST YET.
THEY ARE BEING REFERRED FOR
PUNISHMENT FOR USING OFFENSIVE
LANGUAGE AND UNNECESSARY FORCE.
THE AGENTS COULD BE SUSPENDED
FOR UP TO 14 DAYS.
UNFORTUNATELY, BORDER PATROL IS
NOT THE ONLY ONES BEING ATTACKED
BY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION PIER
AT THE WHITE HOUSE WHITE HOUSE
IS ACCUSING TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT OF CAUSING
CHAOS OVER HIS MOVE WITH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS BACK TO WHERE THEY
CAME FROM.
>> I WILL SAY THIS, THE
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT IS A
FEDERAL AUTHORITY, AND STATE
SHOULD NOT BE MANDATING IT OR
MEDDLING IN IT.
THAT IS JUST ESPECIALLY
GOVERNOR, TEXAS GOVERNOR ABBOTT
WHO HAS A TRACK RECORD OF
CAUSING CHAOS AND CONFUSION AT
THE BORDER.
BUT AGAIN, THIS IS IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT AND A FEDERAL
AUTHORITY.
>> Judge Jeanine: JESSICA AND
I WILL START WITH YOU PIER THE
FACT IS THAT THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T JUST LIE HERE, BUT YOU
HAD THE MOST POWERFUL MAN IN THE
COUNTRY, THE MOST POWERFUL WOMAN
IN THE COUNTRY, VICE PRESIDENT
AND YOU HAD MAXINE WATERS AND
THE REST OF THEM YOU GOT THEM
PREJUDGING A SITUATION, CREATING
A FALSE NARRATIVE WHILE THESE
POWERFUL PEOPLE AND THEY WERE
JUST WRONG.
I MEAN, SHOULD THEY BE IN THESE
POSITIONS MAKING THESE
JUDGMENTS, GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THEY DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
FACTS WERE AT THAT TIME?
>> Jessica: I WILL SAY
JOE BIDEN SHOULD NOT BE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE GOT THIS
WRONG OR KAMALA HARRIS...
>> Judge Jeanine: IT IS REAL
SIMPLE.
>> Jessica: HE SHOULD
BACKTRACK AND SAY HE IS WRONG.
THEY HAVE A 511 PAGE REPORT TO
REFER TO.
THEY DID FIND THERE WAS FAILURE
OF MULTIPLE LEVELS OF THE
AGENCY, LACK OF TRAINING,
DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR ET CETERA AND
THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
BUT WHEN YOU PUBLICLY DEMONIZE
SOMEONE OR AN ORGANIZATION OR
INSTITUTION, IT DOES DAMAGE THE
INSTITUTION, OBVIOUSLY ENTER
THOSE THAT SUPPORT THEM.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT EVEN
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE REPRESENTING
CONSTITUENCIES ALONG THE BORDER
WERE SAYING, "THIS IS ACTUALLY
HOW IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE."
I'M NOT TYPICALLY SOMEONE WHO
RIDES A HORSE AND I DID NOT KNOW
WHAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE GOING O.
WE SHOULD EAT CROW ON THIS
PARTICULAR ONE AND SAY, "WE ARE
WRONG ON THIS AND THESE ARE THE
REPORTS SO THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN."
AND MOVE ON.
>> Judge Jeanine: ISN'T IT
THEIR JOB, JOEY ON THE BORDER
PATROL TO MAKE SURE THINGS AT
THE BORDER GO SMOOTHLY AND TO
NOT LET THERE BE CHAOS AT THE
BORDER AND I'M NOT EVEN
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE --
>> Joey: 40 SOMETHING YEARS
AND THE GOVERNMENT AND THE MEN
ON THAT HORSE.
THAT IS THE HEART OF THIS
PROBLEM.
THERE IS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
AND THEN THE ELITE CLASS THAT
THINK THEY GET TO GOVERN THEM.
TO STAND THERE AND ACCUSE THEM
OF THE EGREGIOUS THING IN THE
WORLD TO BE RACIST AND TRYING TO
WHIP PEOPLE WHEN THEY ARE TRYING
TO ENFORCE A POLICY THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IDEOLOGICALLY
STANDS FUNDAMENTALLY AGAINST.
THINK ABOUT THE ENTIRE AGENCY OF
GOVERNMENT WHOSE MANDATE IS TO
ENFORCE THE BORDER AND CONTROL
THE BORDER AND THEY HAVE PEOPLE
AT THE WHITE HOUSE WHO ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY AND IDEOLOGICALLYT
NOTION.
SO WHAT DO THEY DO?
THEY USE IT AS A SCAPEGOAT,
DEMONIZE THEM AND ANY
TECHNICALITY.
THEY SAY THEY WILL PUNISH THEM
BECAUSE OF OFFENSIVE LANGUAGE.
DON'T YOU THINK RACIAL SLUR THAT
IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY DID?
THEY PROBABLY SAID, "GET THE
HILL BACK."
>> Jessica: THE REPORT OF WHAT
THEY DID SAY.
>> Joey: RICHARD PHELAN SAID
WE HAVE SOME STANDING AGREEMENT
OR POLICY TO LET SPECIFICALLY OF
PEOPLE HAITI IN THE COUNTRY.
WE DO AT THE BORDER CHECKPOINT.
AND PUSH THOSE PEOPLE TOWARDS
THE BORDER ALL DAY LONG.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
DO AND ONLY A HORSE CAN GO.
AND YOU SEE THE MEN OR WOMEN ON
HORSEBACK, THEY GO, WHILE MATT,
THOSE ARE PEOPLE THAT WILL DO
ANYTHING TO PROTECT THIS COUNTR.
THEY SEE A MAN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WHO CAN'T GET THE
SENTENCE OUT OF HIS MOUTH AND
ACCUSE THEM OF THINGS.
THAT MAN IS NOT FIT TO BE
PRESENT THERE PRESIDENT.
>> Judge Jeanine: NOT ONLY
UNFIT BUT IF HE SEES SOMETHING
ON A VIDEOTAPE AND MAKES A
JUDGMENT, WHAT THE HELL IS HE
DOING ON THE WORLD STAGE WITH
LEADERS WHO ARE PLAYING HIM LIKE
A FIDDLE?
>> Jessica: HE'S TURNING ON
THE VERY AGENTS WHOSE MISSION IS
TO PROTECT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO SECURE THE BORDER AND
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
THAT IS THE MISSION OF BORDER
PATROL.
THIS IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF --
THEY ARE PUNISHING THESE GUYS
AND TOOK THEM OFF THE FRONT
LINE.
THEY TOOK THE HORSE PATROL UNIT
OFF OF THAT PART OF THE BORDER
MAKING IT EASIER FOR THE CARTEL
AND CRIMINAL ELEMENTS TO
OPERATE.
THEY WERE DOING THEIR JOB.
TRYING TO PROTECT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FROM ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE THEY ARE
FROM, ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER ILLEGALLY
WITHOUT PERMISSION.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THESE PEOPLE
ARE PEER THEY HAVE NO PAPERWORK,
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE AND
TONS OF CRIMINALS COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
THEY JUST SIMPLY DID THEIR JOB.
FOR JOE BIDEN TO GET UP AND SAY
IMMEDIATELY THEY WERE GUILTY AND
THAT THEY WOULD BE PUNISHED.
TODAY YOU HAVE CUSTOM AND BORDER
PROTECTION COME OUT AND SAY,
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THEY DID
ANYTHING WRONG.
THEY WILL STILL BE PUNISHED IS
THE VERY DEFINITION OF A
POLITICAL WITCH HUNT, AN ABUSE
OF POWER AND I HOPE THESE AGENTS
HAVE RECOURSE AT SOME POINT.
FOR SECRETARY MAY WORK AS FROM
THE BEGINNING TO SAY THEY
WEREN'T WHIPPING ANYBODY.
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE REIGNS, HE
DEFENDED THEM INITIALLY UNTIL HE
GOT A PHONE CALL FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE TO SAVE JOE BIDEN'S
EGO AND PRIDE BECAUSE HE LIED
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AND CONTINUE
THAT NARRATIVE FOR THE SAKE OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE PUSHING IT.
IT IS DESPICABLE AND DISGUSTING
AND EXACTLY WHAT IS WRONG WITH
THE PORTAL POLICY IN GENERAL.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW,
GREG, WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT
THE IDEA OF GOING AFTER BORDER
PATROL, WHO THEY PUT AT THE
BORDER ON HORSES, WHO THEY SAY
PROTECT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND
THEN THEY WANT TO PUNISH THEM
WHEN WE HAVE GOT HOW MANY POUNDS
OF FENTANYL COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY ON ANY GIVEN DAY KILLING
AMERICANS?
AND THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT THIS
SITUATION?
AND THEY ARE NOT EVEN CHECKING
FOR THE FENTANYL?
>> Greg: IF YOU WANT A
DEFINITION OF A TRULY DYSTOPIAN
UNIVERSE, IT IS WHEN THE
AUTHORITY TELLS YOU THAT YOU'VE
DONE NOTHING WRONG, BUT YOU ARE
STILL GETTING PUNISHED.
I MEAN, IT IS THE OLD-LINE, SHOW
ME THE PERSON AND I WILL SHOW
YOU THE CRIME.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THIS IS.
THIS WOULD MAKE PROUD AND RIGHT
UP THERE WITH TWO PLUS TWO
EQUALS FIVE WERE ORWELL 1984.
WE FOUND NOTHING WRONG BUT YOU
WILL BE SENTENCED TO FIVE YEARS
OF HARD LABOR.
THAT IS THE THING THAT I THINK
SHOULD DISCUSSED EVERYBODY IN
TERMS OF OFFENSIVE LANGUAGE.
THE REAL OFFENSIVE LANGUAGE WAS
COMPARING BORDER PATROL TO
SLAVE OWNERS AND CALLING -- THE
USELESS LANGUAGE THAT IS
DRAMATIC LANGUAGE.
IT IS HORRIFIC, BRITTLE, THEY
WILL PAY!
IT IS LIKE THAT RASH, HYPER
DRAMATIC TWEET THAT GETS ALL OF
THE ATTENTION AND WHEN IT TURNS
OUT YOU ARE DEAD WRONG, THE
CORRECTION IS A LITTLE MOUSE
SQUEAK.
AND NOBODY, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
PUTTING UP ON PAGE B, 35 SO NO
ONE FINDS IT.
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR A LOT OF
REASONS.
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA TO
NOT CARE ABOUT AN ISSUE UNTIL AN
AMERICAN VILLAIN TO AMPLIFY.
THERE WAS A LOT OF BAD STUFF
GOING ON AT THE BORDER.
YOU BRING UP FENTANYL.
THERE WAS A LOT OF CHAOS,
SUFFERING, COYOTES, RAPE THAT
THERE IS NO STORY AND THAT AN
AMERICAN DARTH VADER.
YOU KNOW HOW DESPERATE WE WERE
ON THE SHOW TO GET PEOPLE TO
COVER THE BORDER?
AND THEN COME ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE SPIGOT THAT WAS TURNED ON
NOT TURNED ON IN FULL FORCE
AND THEN AROUND THE CLOCK AND IT
WAS INCREDIBLE.
IT WAS ANOTHER COLLUDING
ENTERPRISE OF MEDIA AND
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO CREATE A
HOAX.
THIS IS WHY PEOPLE HAVE LOST
TRUST IN THE MEDIA.
THEY HAVE LOST TRUST IN THE
GOVERNMENT.
THEY HAVE SEEN THE DRINKING
BLEACH HOAX THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION HOAX.
THEY SEE THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
MEDIA IN BED TOGETHER AND THEY
CAN'T TRUST THEM.
THEN, THEY AMPLIFY THE STORY AND
THEY BURY OTHERS.
SO WE TALKED ABOUT THE HUNTER
BIDEN STUFF BEING BURIED, BUT 50
PLUS MIGRANTS DIED IN A TRUCK
DRIVEN BY A METH HEAD.
THAT STORY GOT WHAT, A HALF AN
HOUR?
THINK ABOUT THAT.
BIDEN CARED